[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
أشعر اليوم بقدر كبير من
الحرية أكثر مما شعرت به في
السنوات الأربع الماضية
جيدًا ، فأنا ناخب
رابح ولكن آه إذا فاز بايدن ،
فسأدعمه لذا هذا ما يجب
أن أقوله
أعتقد أنه سوف يقوم بعمل جيد وآمل
لذلك لم تكن هذه هي أمريكا التي نشأت فيها ،
إنها ليست أمريكا التي
قمت بالتصويت فيها منذ أن كان عمري 18 عامًا
ولكني الآن
أشعر أنني أستطيع التنفس مرة أخرى لقد قمت بالتصويت  بالنسبة
لجو بايدن ،
لكني لا أشعر بالكثير من الفرح اليوم ، كان
العالم بأسره
يشاهدنا لرؤيتنا نبذ
نظام ترامب الفظيع وبدلاً
من ذلك قرر جزء كبير من بلدنا
اعتناقه ،
ما زلت خائفًا لأنه يثبت فقط
كيف أن أمريكا  منقسم إلى حد كبير
إذا كان أي شيء جيدًا أنه قريب
لأنه لا يمكننا تجاهل التبذير
الذي لا يمكننا التفكير فيه على أنه مجرد قضية
صغيرة ترفع من تاريخ بلدنا ، فنحن
نعلم أنه أمر كبير
نحتاج إلى معالجته  أخيرًا يكون لدينا
رئيس
في منصبه يهتم
بالأشخاص وآمل أن نتمكن من ذلك  rt تهتم
ببعضها البعض مرة
أخرى وليس لدي رئيس مستعد
لتقسيم
الجميع ، أردت فقط الاتصال
ومشاركة شخص ما كم
أنا متحمس ستكون هناك امرأة
ملونة في البيت الأبيض
لابنتي حتى تتمكن ابنتي من
رؤيتي "  أنا متحمسة جدًا لها لتكون قادرة
على القيام
بذلك وتنشأ وهي تعلم أن هذا
ممكن وأن هذا ما تريد
القيام به وهذا ما يمكنها
فعله ويمكنها فعل أي شيء
أنا مهاجرة جئت إلى هذا البلد في عام 1965
و  لطالما كنت فخورًا جدًا
بكوني أمريكيًا ،
كنت على استعداد لبيع شركتي ومغادرة
هذا البلد ،
لذا بالطريقة التي أشعر بها أنني لا أستطيع حتى وصف
أنني جمهوري ولكني صوتت
لجو بايدن وآمل أن يربح الله.
توقف عن هراء هذا الثور من رفع دعاوى
قضائية لمحاولة سحبها ،
نحتاج إلى الابتعاد عن ذلك
، يجب أن يتغلب على نفسه
ليس لديهم أي فكرة عما فعلوه ، لقد
تركوا كرههم يعميهم ، لقد تركوا
الكراهية تقول أي شخص  لكن
ترامب آمل أن يتمكن مؤيدو ترامب من الحصول على "ل"
وأتمنى ب  استعدوا واكتشفوا
أن الأمور آمل أن
تتحسن آمل أن تكون هناك حزمة تحفيز تالية في
أقرب وقت ممكن تكافح الكثير من
العائلات أنا بالتأكيد
أعاني مع
عائلتي لقد خدمت بلدي في الجيش
خلال ثلاث حروب
أكثر من 40 عامًا وأريد أن أرى
نهاية هذا الفيروس وأعتقد أن
الشخص الوحيد الذي يمكنه إنهاء هذا الفيروس
وإعادتنا إلى الحياة الطبيعية هو جو بايدن هنا
نودع 2020 ونرحب بعام 2021 مع بقاء
الاثنين في البيت الأبيض.